they're accusing me of being a
journalist asking provocative questions
about ukraine and photographing military
sites but you put all those together and
you've essentially got through the
russian states perspective a foreign
journalist getting ready to spread
stories about the russian military that
run counter to the state's official
narrative and they introduced in early
march about a week after the invasion of
ukraine a new law with a sentence of up
to 15 years for just that
talk to me about what drives somebody
to do
the things that you have chosen to do as
pursuits
uh there's been a lot of different
drivers at different points i guess over
the course of my career to start off
with i
was i mean i i don't think it's too i
don't think i'm too ashamed to say that
at the beginning i was kind of quite
keen to try and
like stamp my mark on the world a phrase
i've used once before is a young man
wanting to slay dragons but i kind of
grew up in the post-dragon era um and i
you know i wanted to sort of get out
there and see the world but it was
definitely quite a dose of
uh i guess ego
wound in wrapped up in that and i quite
liked the
sort of self image of the i guess the
kind of
thoughtful grizzled explorer plodding
through the icy wastes you know with
only his
mind for company
but thankfully as the uh as the last
sort of you know 13 or so years have
gone by i've become a little bit more
considered and it's nowadays uh i'd say
roughly 50 50 between wanting to get out
and challenge myself uh
physically in
wild places you know to be in the
wilderness or lesser known little you
know seldom visited people and get some
insight into into their lives and their
worlds um and i guess the thing that
draws all that together is just a strong
sense of curiosity which has never waned
it's interesting to think about what can
drive people to do the things that they
want to do
when in the beginning some of it might
have been recognition or
status or a desire for a claim or
respect from the people that you admire
can take you a hell of a long way
yeah i don't i think to be fair my my
sort of my
world or my
sphere that how i imagined things going
didn't quite stretch to
a claim or recognition it was
i mean i wrote in my first book about
going off during i studied up in
newcastle where i think you are from or
studied yeah
and
in the summer holidays i would scrape
together the few pennies i had and you
know i work in bars or putting up
marquis or whatever or summer and then
at the end i would have a few weeks
where i could go off to somewhere
obscure and i quite
liked when i came back that everyone had
been you know partying all summer and
i'd been this just sort of
absence and uh coming back and suddenly
having
a story to tell and something
interesting to say i don't think i ever
imagined that i would make a career out
of any of this and
a career is is a sort of you know
commas type term when you do something
like this because it's scraping together
all sorts of different things there's no
kind of one single thing that i do
um so i guess it was
perhaps more vanity than a desire for
recognition or anything else that sort
of drove me to go out and sort of you
know explore yes given the dancing
around of what it is that you do people
might not be familiar
how do you define what it is that you do
are you an adventurer are you a a global
travels journalist what are you
um
i would say i'm an adventure travel
writer but that's three words which is a
lot
so i guess just i mean i used to
allow myself to get into long drawn out
you know protracted conversations or
debates about the different meanings of
the two words adventurer and explorer
and i still believe frankly that the
word explorer is something
basically from a bygone age with the
exception of scientists
astronauts uh
deep sea uh submersibles would that be
breaking new ground for you going to
places that haven't yet been seen
exactly i mean
there is a case to argue that we're all
exploring in some sense because if you
haven't been sung before you are
exploring it but then i think that's
just the verb rather than the adjective
the term explorer
that said
the other people who do similar things
to me have for quite a while just use
the word explorer so i decided to stop
fighting it and i don't tend to
self-identify as that but i no longer
quibble about it when people describe me
as that um but but in reality what i do
is go to places
check things out come back write about
it speak about it and work out what's
next
what was that triathlon thing that you
did
the triathlon was uh the concept behind
that was to
travel the length of the
europe asia border or the perceived or
supposed continental boundary between
europe and asia
uh to try and
explore what that is what that means and
if it has any
relevance in the modern world brackets
it doesn't
um we all at school learn that there are
seven continents and we kind of just
grew up you know having taken that for
granted we just imbibed that information
yeah there's seven continents but
there's not clearly you look at a map
and antarctica is a continent australia
is clearly a continent big i think the
dictionary definition of continent is a
large contiguous land mass surrounded by
a body of water so
africa is arguably a continent although
it's connected to arabia which is
connected to
eurasia as i call it
so eurasia is very clearly one big
continent with this sort of
complicated wiggly line through the
middle of it and i started looking into
what that line where that line came from
how it was drawn and the first person to
um
bifurcate europe from asia was an
aximanda i think a an ancient greek
geographer and philosopher 2 600 years
ago and
he even back then it was this
complicated medley of geographical
features uh it was
uh the as of sea the
the
managed depression the caspian sea the
don river it was this real you know dog
leg of messy features to divide europe
from asia
and that became important to people
predominantly west of that line and over
the
ensuing 26 centuries it meant different
things to different people at different
times but often it was the divide
between enlightenment and barbarism or
democracy and despotism or
christianity and islam all these
different things but the the line that
is today the sort of commonly accepted
geographical border between europe and
asia is it was was perceived by a
conceived rather by a swedish
cartographer in the 17th century
and it's the ural mountains the ural
river
the caspian sea
the caucasus mountains and then the
black sea so again this weird
combination of stuff so i started to
travel the length of that border by
human power um so skiing the length of
the oral
mountain range uh the ural river rises
in the southern foothills of the ural
mountains so paddle down the length of
the euro river which blows into the
caspian after 1509 miles
uh and then cycle from the mouth of the
caspian
around the edge of the caspian across
the caucasus mountains along the turkish
black sea coast to istanbul and along
the way i wanted to ask people
what they thought about this border
whether they were aware that they lived
on a border whether they if they did
whether they identified as european or
asian or eurasian or both or neither or
just kazak or russian or turkish or
georgian or whatever
and uh it was
5200 miles and took eight months and uh
by the end unsurprisingly i found that
very little people
cared about this continental divide
how many times did you cross backward
and forward are you pretty pretty close
to being able to sit on that line and
wiggle down it well on the river it was
very easy because you're just on the
river you are on the border you know one
night uh we would i was doing this with
a with a with a friend one night weird
camp in europe the next night we camp in
asia it was just wherever we saw the
first kind of decent sort of landing
spot in this inflatable
tandem kayak we bought in a siberian
village um
in the mountains the technical border is
the watershed of the ural mountains so
there we would pass back and forth
across it
uh
you know sometimes once a week sometimes
that we were three months in the
mountains uh so i i guess we passed back
and forth over it maybe a dozen times
during that three month period and then
once we were cycling we were always on
uh let me think
we were on the
asian side of the border until we got
down and crossed into azerbaijan
and so everything north of the caucasus
is technically europe and then south of
that you're into asia
um and that's kind of interesting we
passed in within geographical europe we
passed through this area in russia
called kamikia
which is a um it's one of many places
that russia calls an autonomous republic
uh it's not autonomous of course but
this place uh a predominantly buddhist
uh sort of enclave within russia the
people living there the calmix uh
migrated from mongolia about 450 years
ago
uh they speak an archaic form of
mongolian they are ethnically mongolian
they speak sorry they practice buddhism
it's just not something you'd expect to
find in what we term europe next to that
you've got dagestan which is another
part of russia which is um predominantly
uh muslim and they've had a long sort of
long-running low-level islamist
insurgency there's been you know it's
often touted as the most dangerous place
in europe and whenever someone goes
through there or you know for tv they
say god isn't this place edgy but of
course we found it to be the friendliest
place we visited on the on the entire
journey um so
yeah that was a long answer to your
europe asia crossing the border question
but uh from
azerbaijan almost we were then in the in
the asian side of the border uh and
georgia was the only place really where
people
seem to care about that concept of the
border
um what do you think that's due to
quite a few different reasons i think
historically uh georgians have seen
themselves as um
i mean it's a very ancient place it
converted in about 350 as a
in as a sort of
independent kingdom it converted to
christianity so it's a very early combat
christianity and it lies within the kind
of the wider realm of islam for the
better term
uh they are desperate to join the
european union
um i should think that will never happen
because they are too important a kind of
uh meeting point between different
powers uh they
you know they've got turkey to one side
russia to the north iran just across the
border further south they're
in the council of europe which has about
50 countries and so every
government building has a eu flag
outside it because the council of europe
and the eu flag are the same
and i think they just see themselves as
kind of uh isolated they
even though much of
a third or so of russia is in europe
they see russia as being part of that
kind of other block maybe following the
asian tradition and they want to be part
of
the the european community um
so yeah for quite a few different
reasons it's it's not entirely clear and
it's something i'm hoping to get back
there at some point to look into further
but i think they just they also see
themselves as as um
inheriting the phoenician and then the
greek traditions from the ancient world
uh the the phoenician seafarers kind of
settled the coast of georgia and so they
see that as as part of their heritage
if dagestan was one of the warmest
places that you visited during that
triathlon which i mean it's a triathlon
where you skied and both paddled in a
kayak so i guess it's definitely a an
upgraded or amended triathlon what was
one of the more dicey places that you
went to
um
we
while in
uh georgia we accidentally crossed the
border into south pacific which is
a region of georgia that russia annexed
in 2008
in a short five-day war they bombed uh i
mean even the capital tbilisi and
strategic sites around the capital
and uh we
we were following google maps on a phone
and it gave us this bit of advice to get
to where we wanted to go
you've arrived at this road down some
mountain valley path go up the road for
about a mile cross the river and then
head down the road on the other side and
then you'll soon be in this town
but at the bridge there were police and
they said the bridge is closed and they
wouldn't explain why they were georgian
police
and
they gave no reason and during this
journey i'd been arrested in russia
probably three times i think um it's
in remote areas in russia in russia it's
very hard not to get in trouble with the
authorities frankly if you're a
foreigner uh being in remote areas is
automatically qualifying you for
suspicion oh i think that you're doing
some sort of surveying clandestine
[ __ ]
exactly as if you'd send a wanker on a
pair of skis rather than use a satellite
but um
yeah we were kind of fed up with being
stymied by the authorities even though
this time it was the georgians and so we
just went half a mile back down the
river which was only ankle deep pushed
our bikes across it was only
40 meters wide or something got out the
bank on the other side it was the height
of summer so the water was very low got
out the bank on the other side got onto
the road we wanted to follow and started
cycling happy that we you know got it
got away with it we'll be in that town
later that afternoon for a hostel and a
shower and a good feed
and
in less than a minute a military jeep
was sped up behind us and this soldier
jumped out
and i noticed first the russian flag on
his arm
and
it confused me because the russian
border was uh i think probably 30 or 50
miles north
and so i you know thought what are you
doing here and i asked him that and he
didn't like that as a question and asked
me what are you what are you doing here
yeah yeah and then he said this is south
ossetia and it turned out sort of a
later uh review of maps that we had
crossed there's a tiny little in the
very southeast corner of south ossetia
there's this tiny little promontory of
land that sticks further south and we're
just if it's a finger we had just
crossed the tip of the fingernail just
at this tiny little area and the river
was the border and on yeah the guy then
pointed out that there were guard towers
around us and barbed wire and everything
that we hadn't noticed
um and so we were we were sort of you
know taken in for the night putting a
cell
question taken to court everything like
that um so that was a little bit sketchy
um the journey the after about five
hours of interrogation from russian
security officials they then drove us to
shkinvali the capital of south assetia
which is this sort of supposedly
standalone um state but of course it's
entirely run by russia um but the south
africans were if anything more angsty
and they
the journey in the night we got stopped
at one point some guy
more or less tried to rob us while we're
in police custody which is quite unusual
um and then in the castle we put in this
sort of you know the cell was fine it
was it was nothing too bad but then they
hailed us interrogated us for hours and
hours and hours the next day never fed
us or anything like that and then
finally when we were in court i
complained when they say is there
anything you'd like to say i said yeah
we haven't been fed and the judge got
angry at the police and forced them to
feed us and we got a nice place of uh
sort of uzbek plov
and then we're after paying our fine
handed back across the border to the
georgian authorities and carried on on
our way so that was probably the
hairiest moment
uh sort of politically
but the the three-month ski through the
urals
we were starting
about 200 miles north of the arctic
circle on the arctic coast in
february which is really cold um so we
had temperatures down to about -45 i
think
um during that ski in tents blizzards
and winds um which pushes the wind chill
down even further
uh
there was a lot of flat light it was
hard to sort of gauge avalanche risk as
risks at various points on our way
through the ural mountains and the maps
we were working off were these old
soviet um sort of military
cartographic survey maps from the 1950s
so we were working off these kind of
slightly approximated contour lines and
suddenly you know we just find ourselves
clawing our way up a 60 degree slope
so that was all quite um sketchy as well
i guess what was that place that you
went to that you said is the most
sparsely populated cold
place on the planet was that part of the
triathlon or was that the no that
walking thing that was this year um oh
that was this year that's an area called
yakutia um
so the most vastly populated country on
earth is mongolia and mongolia has and
let me get this right
uh
three people i believe per square
kilometer
but yakutia
has three square kilometers per person
no way and what so what's your coutinho
yakuti is a country all of its own
yakutia or as it's also known
republic or republic of sakha is a an
administrative region of russia um it's
basically the same size as india i think
i worked out it's 94 the size of india
but there's only one million people um
india has 1.4 billion i think 1.3
billion yes so you've got an entire
country nearly the size of india with
the population of newcastle city center
yes yeah on a friday night um
it's it's and most of it is relatively
uninhabitable um about half of it sits
north of the arctic circle where would
this be on a map let's say someone's
looking at a map is it just running
across the top of russia if you go to
yeah if you go to beijing
and then go about two thousand miles
north you're probably in the middle of
yakutia um and it goes up to the north
coast but it's a huge uh area of russia
it's sort of heads right down
sort of close to lake baikal which is in
the middle of siberia um it's but it's
absolutely it's the size of india but
it's up tucked away in the northeast of
russia there's only one more kind of
district to the east of it this place
called chacoca and that's the peninsula
part that kind of reaches out towards um
alaska
uh so it's absolutely vast and up there
the
you know the coldest inhabited place on
earth this city called virgo is in
yakutia just close to where i started
this trek earlier this year
and they had a temperature about 100
years ago recorded and it was minus
i can't remember off top i think it was
minus 68.4
degrees centigrade celsius so really
cold um you know you don't want to be
outdoors
in that much uh but the average winter
daily low temperatures in in much of it
are below minus 40. it's really really
cold um and
yeah that was a very different
experience earlier this year in russia
because when i was there in 2017
it was
peace time but three days after i
arrived this year uh peacetime ended and
uh
well to be fair to the ukrainians they
would say peacetime ended in 2014 when
crimea was annexed but
the rest of ukraine was invaded three
days after i arrived so the rest of the
journey was a little bit dicey what
happened though
uh well i spent the first two months
hiking along this frozen river starting
from a little town in the middle of
yakutia hiking north
a couple of frozen rivers in fact up
towards the arctic coast and it was
really interesting the reason i went was
to go and
see and meet the people living there see
what their lives are like
a lot of the people there are
in fact the majority of people there are
ethnically indigenous siberians so
they've lived in the area for hundreds
of years
and have survived sort of pre-pre the
russian
colonization of the area
about 400 years ago they they you know
they survived
by
hunting by herding by living
often
semi-nomadic lifestyles in this
incredibly harsh sort of inhospitable
part of the world so i wanted to go and
see meet these people and that's what i
did for the first two months had a
really interesting time i would spend
about a week out in the wilderness
hiking along camping in my tent
temperatures down to nearly -50
and then once a week i'd stop into a
village and meet interesting people and
learn about their lives
but after about three weeks i was um i
was taken into a police station in the
only one town along my whole route from
the start of the finish there was one
town in the middle how long was the
route going to be in terms of time uh
two months
and uh oh and you'd already done two
months so you must have been nearly
finished no no so
after about one month halfway along
right
i was i was taken in by the police
and questioned and accused of uh
committing journalism while traveling on
a tourist visa and asking people
provocative questions about ukraine
and there was this long sort of back and
forth questioning
you know interrogation process
and at the end of which i realized well
they're they're going to find me
2 000 rubles which is about 20 pounds so
not um actually in the course of the
previous month that had gone from being
worth about 20 pounds to being about
four pounds i was about to say yeah the
hyperinflation would have given you a
great exchange rate well i would have if
uh all bank cards haven't stopped
working sometime earlier so i was just
on the cash that i'd taken with me by
this point
um but uh i realized that i could pay
this fine and then just get out into the
wilderness and carry on they weren't
going to hustle me after that at least
these two policemen the only two were
you on your own for this trip by the way
yes yeah just me
um and so i so i'd left them carried on
walking got up to the coast spent the
final two weeks walking along the frozen
arctic sea ice which was absolutely
beautiful just this huge expanse of
whiteness stretching out to the northern
horizon and there were um aurora
borealis playing over the sky at night
incredible starscapes it was really
sublime serene
but then i reached my final town this uh
this port town called tixi
which used to have about 15 000 people i
think and as it turned out more than
half the people there
uh are military personnel
anyway once i arrived in dixie it didn't
take long for the police to
um to arrest me once again question me
once again and this time i was accused
of the same things
but with the added accusation or
allegation of photographing military
sites
uh so i was i was taken to court once
again it's a bit of a sort of kangaroo
court sham trial late at night
um found guilty
and i thought i was
they told me that i was going to be
banned from russia for five years i'd
have to pay a 50 pound fine this time
and i would have to leave the country
and so i thought that i would fly back
down to yakutsk the capital city of the
region that i'd flown into
get a flight out the country and and be
done with it but
it turns out that i was escorted by a
marshall
down to yakutsk uh and then another one
picked me up at the airport in yakutsk
took me to a detention center and i was
locked up for the next uh month until
finally i was deported so it was all
quite a
the thing that worried me most is i
never knew i was never told how long i
would be locked up they said you're here
until we deport you and i said when's
that and they said oh we don't know
there's paperwork
um but then as i launched i lodged an
appeal i managed to hire a local lawyer
and uh the appeal was immediately
rejected just out of hand they said that
my uh my charges were too serious and
had a political nature to them
uh so they were accusing me of being a
journalist asking provocative questions
about ukraine and photographing military
sites
but you put all those together and
you've essentially got through the
russian states
uh perspective
a foreign journalist getting ready to
spread
stories about the russian military that
run counter to the state's official
narrative and they introduced in early
march about a week after the invasion of
ukraine a new law with a sentence of up
to 15 years for just that so while i was
in there i was thinking you know any
minute they might just take me back to
court try me again with this sort of
criminal charge
and i could be here until i'm nearly 50.
um so it was a it was a pretty
hair-raising time mostly frankly boring
frustrating
uh enraging you know i've never really
been prone to
uh a hot temper but while i was in there
i found myself having sort of irrational
fits of rage
at one point they dragged me out the
cell in handcuffs and suddenly i was
just um
thrust in front of a tv camera and i was
interviewed for state tv news they just
threw all the same accusations at me as
the police had in court
um so that felt like i was being kind of
prepared or run through the court public
opinion
and things could get really quite bad
after that um
brittany greiner the american basketball
player she's still in russia she's been
in uh in prison for i think about 120
days four months more perhaps
maybe closer to six months now actually
um
and there's uh british uh people who
have been detained in sort of around
mariupol
and they've all been attendance to death
presumably uh
two of two or three of them now and i
think two more about to follow along
with a swede and a croatian um
presumably with a view i i i think can
hope that they won't be executed they'll
probably be um sort of used or bargained
for prisoner swaps um but there was just
while i was on the inside while i was in
the prison there was just always hanging
over me the possibility that they're
going to use me make an example of me
and i could spend
months or even years in this place so
frankly the fact that i'm out now is is
uh i do marvel at it every few days uh
how lucky i've been to actually be
released yeah it seems like a roll of
the dice i'm going to guess that some of
the people that were detained were
detained for probably no more or maybe
even less than
what you were detained for and they're
still there and now potentially facing
the death penalty except they would
happen to be in a a different area with
a different code and the wrong judge and
the wrong inspector or whatever well the
the folks who have been given the death
penalty they they were charged with uh
being mercenaries and uh sort of
partaking in a foreign war as the
russians see it a little bit yeah so
they were fighting with the ukrainian
army but one of them had been
uh in the ukrainian special forces i
think for several years already and is
also a ukrainian citizen but they've
just thrown the book at him because he's
also got uk citizenship but brittany
greiner she just had or allegedly i mean
there's no evidence that we know of
allegedly she just had a vape cartridge
with trace amounts of hash or cbd oil or
something like that uh and she's you
know she's been in prison for
best part of half a year
so that's more trivial sentenced to 15
years it was uh
nine years i think it was maybe maybe it
was nine but i think they wanted nine
and a half that was it yeah they wanted
no she's done half yeah exactly um yeah
that was just last week i think um we
learned we
learned about dubai has a particularly
strict drugs policy and this guy flew
from las vegas to dubai
and
had had some
thc
in something while he was in vegas
got pancreatitis in dubai and then when
they did a urine test of him he was
found to have trace amounts of thc in
his urine and that constitutes
possession in dubai
i don't even know what to say about that
that's uh wild
and that seems like that's
largely just yeah it's just shitty luck
um yeah okay so go take me back like you
get you get taken in who in their right
mind when
russia has just invaded the ukraine
is helping a british journalist
who was [ __ ] about taking photos and
writing stuff
for a laugh
and because that's what he likes to do
who
who was prepared to give you any
assistance why would they weren't able
to do a great deal frankly there's not
really many diplomatic levers remaining
between britain and russia
but they they
tried to help where they could they were
also six time zones away in moscow so
that there was that
um i had a local friend who uh you know
bought some books to the prison for me
to read that was that was very kind of
her
or him um and
uh
the the lawyer that i hired was just a
local lawyer
who was prepared to do that for the
several hundred dollars that he was paid
to do it but his job was basically just
to
take my case present it to the court
have it rejected and that was more or
less the end of it um i believe he did
help or certainly tried to
expedite the movement of papers from the
court system up in this port city on the
north port town on the north where i was
arrested down to the capital where i was
being held which uh sped things up a
little bit any
one further day of delay for the papers
not getting there apparently would have
led to me not being deported at that
time they only deport people at certain
times so i was deported in late may and
the next window was going to be late
july so that would have been another two
months already and had i been there for
another two months as the situation
continued to deteriorate in ukraine as
the british and russian relationship
continued to disintegrate too
um there's i think a good chance had it
been there another two months that the
my case would have been sort of picked
up by the authorities i've wanted to
release you you would have been more
valuable to them exactly i would have
been retried with a criminal charge for
either uh that that um
fake news charge that they brought in or
just simply uh espionage because they
said i was creeping around in in remote
areas where where you're not really
meant to be and they said i was
photographing military sites
so you're not going to go back to russia
any time soon
i can't i can't for the next five years
uh but i i mean i would love to go back
to russia i i have a lot of affection
for the place and for the vast majority
of the people i've met in russia
who uh and there are of course plenty of
exceptions to this people who are
zealously in favor of everything that's
happening not just outwardly but also
inwardly
um but there are lots of people who are
just essentially victims and prisoners
of their own regime and this doesn't
mean that their
lives are being torn up being separated
but it does mean that they aren't free
to speak to say what they think to write
to publish what they think
to protest or anything like that so i i
do hope that russia sees
uh
reform or revolution frankly in in my
lifetime and i do get to go back but
until that day i wouldn't be sensible or
safe to do so how culpable do you think
citizens are
for being
complicit
convinced perhaps by
malicious
ideas and ideologies as a part of a
regime that they don't know anything
else but that
it's a really good question i think
that's um one of the most
interesting difficult and
important questions that there is at the
moment and i've wrestled with this quite
a lot and i don't have any
uh
definitive answer for it i go through
phases of feeling and thinking different
things but broadly speaking
um
plenty of people in russia
are just completely sold on the
propaganda they've been fed they
genuinely think that the ukrainian
leadership and governance is fascistic
that they are neo-nazis um you only have
to watch you know 10 20 minutes of state
tv news in russia
to
to just get just the level of
[ __ ] that they're being fed
now there is um
there is censorship so it is hard to
access uh
external media or news that basically
all the independent media has been shut
down there are a few remaining but they
are only remaining because they are
toeing the government line
but it is still possible or at least it
was when i left and i believe it is it
is still possible to get to visit quite
a lot of foreign news sites
um but they might not be in russians
they probably aren't understandable to
the vast majority of people outside
russia and i i i think the censorship on
external websites has been
a lot more rigorous on uh russian
language outlets
so there are there are
plenty of people in russia who know what
they're being told is a lie but can't do
anything about it and frankly stand to
gain nothing
and really achieve nothing by speaking
up you know all they'll do is endanger
their
themselves their families um and they'll
just bring the wrath of the state down
on them
uh
there are people who are cynically
exploiting the situation you only have
to see the little clips put onto twitter
from some of the main panel discussions
on russia one the main news channel to
see that some people are just you know
tub thumping and are just happily
uh
repeating parroting anything that putin
or his propaganda machine says
so it's it's it's tricky
this question i suppose is coming up
most often with regard to in you know to
international sports tournaments
so should russian
competitors be allowed to compete
uh they were banned from uh russians and
belarusians i think were banned from
wimbledon
but aren't from the cincinnati open in
ohio at the moment
um
there was a story today two russian i
believe two russian female tennis
players were having a match and then a
spectator who had a ukrainian flag
draped around her was
ordered by the tournament to remove it
because one of the players complained
now people who seem to show and russians
abroad who seem to show an open
prejudice against ukraine
i think that's a problem and i don't
think that there's uh an excuse for that
because they don't have to say anything
especially if you're in the middle of a
tennis match
well exactly
um and so there's that there's there's
saying
nothing is very different to saying
something and i don't think we should
condemn people for
an absence of
protest where it's so dangerous to
protest
that said the longer the war goes on and
the more it starts to feel like the only
way for the water end
is through
a
vast popular uprising in russia for
which there isn't the appetite that's
what you think
one of the solutions or one of the
routes out of this current conflict is
is for the war to be won from within
russia itself
yeah well i mean there's only three i
suppose one is uh some sort of uh
treaty essentially concessions from
ukraine giving russia what it's taken
and calling it a day politically i don't
see that happening or at least not for a
long while there is still the appetite
in ukraine to carry on fighting
the zelenski does still seem to have the
support of the majority of the country
to not concede to russia
um the other would be well the other two
would be ukraine winning or losing the
war i.e ukraine being entirely annexed
by russia
or russia being entirely repelled from
ukraine but that would probably as
things stand at the moment have to
include the crimean peninsula as well
i don't see that happening uh or not
again not anytime soon the saddest thing
about this war is it looks set to grind
on for months and potentially even years
but the only other option i i see short
of things escalating to some sort of
nuclear hellscape
is is
the people of russia turning on their
government rising up but and there are
plenty of people in russia who want that
to happen but not enough i in my opinion
i think that
lots of even russia predominantly older
people and people uh
away from the more cosmopolitan
urban centers where i think there's a
little bit more awareness of and access
to foreign media
people away from those places and older
people support the war and support putin
and putin is still seen as the
essentially the savior who bought
stability to russia after the crazed
kind of kleptocracy of the 1990s after
the soviet union was dissolved
there was just that crazy period where
all the oligarchs everything was just
robbed people grabbed whatever they
could they sold off whatever they could
and uh it was around about the time
putin came into power that that sort of
lessened that's not to say that putin
and his cronies have continued you know
plundering the country as as much as
they can and various estimates of
putin's private wealth stretched out to
about the 200 billion dollar mark
although he can't really take that away
with him the minute he's out of office
he's he's probably dead
um so that's a really long rambling and
self-contradicting answer to your
question and the simple answer is i
really i just i don't have a perfect
answer to that question but i do want
people to think about it and discuss it
more because i think it's really
important i do
worry about the sort of rise and spread
of russophobia um because a lot of
people aren't culpable they don't have a
say over what happens and the incredible
crackdown on the early um sort of uh
protests that were went right across the
country in the first few days of the war
but within a week about 15 000 people
have been arrested many of whom were
thrown in prison so
protest in a state that has quite such a
huge police and military presence is
nigh on impossible it's kind of the
difference between the art and the
artist thing right that you have a
population and then you have populists
and then you have the politicians that
are controlling them and i think that
yeah it
it does suck it it's unfortunate that
russians are being tarred with a brush
that they perhaps didn't choose
that their government has put in place
for them and yeah it's kind of like what
you were talking about to do with sports
athletes have come before in the russian
um athletics federation
and they've been doping which means that
now in future you don't get to play
anymore even if you're clean i don't
think that any of the russian athletes
are clean i think that this is the sort
of thing that's going to be continuing
in any case my point being there is
something that feels unfair about that
but you have to draw a line at some
point and you have to say look the
difference between this being individual
and this being systemic and even if it
means that out of 100 athletes
10 of them might be clean or out of 100s
population people 10 of them might be
pro putin or whatever um it is very very
difficult and i think that's where the
where the nuance sort of comes in
sport i think raises some really
interesting different examples because
uh so tennis is a good example because
you don't really play tennis outside of
the olympics i think you don't really
play tennis for your country there's
also that uh is it the davis cup europe
versus america but you don't play tennis
for your country you play as an
individual it's the same with golf
predominantly
but a football team or a olympic
squad that's a bit different and i you
know i think it's right that for example
the
the uefa final was taken away from
russia pretty much as soon as the
invasion happened it also wasn't
feasible
from a security perspective to get all
those many probably tens of thousands of
people into russia for that game anyway
so it was a bit of a no-brainer
but if you are
in a team that is flying the russian
flag and sort of you know that
i suppose if you're if you're
uh having the anthem played for you upon
victory i mean the the national anthems
aren't played at the end of a tournament
in wimbledon for example uh when nadal
wins they don't play at the spanish
national anthem on the once every 80
years that a brit wins or an english
scottish person wins you don't get that
anthem because it's individuals playing
but a football team is a very different
idea and the olympics is the same
because the olympics is all about well
supposedly i guess international
cohesion but it's about countries
competing with each other on the global
stage um so sports does have those
differing kind of examples and and again
it's it's sometimes difficult to draw
the line but i suppose if you are a team
wearing the flag having the anthem then
you stand for that country and to
compete in international sports should
be a privilege and i don't think uh
countries for example china with its
awful human rights record i don't think
they should have been allowed to host
the winter olympics let alone arguably
compete at the winter olympics although
if you start ticking off all the
dictatorships and autocracies and people
with bad human rights records the
olympics is going to start looking
like um
well kind of the you know eu games or
something
to say the least i think so given let's
say that you're doing these long trips i
mean you've done
walking to the northernmost points of a
bunch of different places cycling around
tons of places
how do you renormalize coming back to
everyday life
after you've been away in these trips
you mentioned before that you
during your time at uni or whatever
would come back and kind of have this
new
uh
viewpoint that you would have been
absent that you would have done
something that was different but now i
mean you've got
family you've got friends you've got
i don't know it's you're coming back to
a very different sort of world you have
changed an awful lot and yet the world
is continued the same how do you
renormalize
uh it's there's no sort of one way i
suppose it's different every time and
frankly broadly speaking gets easier
every time i go back and it depends a
lot on how long you've been away so my
journeys have varied from two months to
four and a half years and coming back
after four and a half years that's odd
because your life has become whatever it
is that you're doing for four and a half
years uh yeah constantly moving on the
road for four and a half years but going
away for two or three months is it's a
fair old amount of time the thing that's
most different when i come back is not
the fact that i'm
back home or back in the uk is the fact
that i'm no longer waking up in a tent
each morning and and hiking or cycling
or kayaking or whatever it is so it's
the i guess it's that change from
uh
movement to
just well no longer flux you're just
you're in the same spot it's that
standing still
at first i get a bit sort of you know
itchy so when i got back from
russia
i arrived at
about six in the morning at heathrow
my girlfriend and an uncle came to pick
me up we had breakfast she went to work
i came home
and i just felt i mean i i hadn't really
slept but i suddenly felt just kind of
you know
stir crazy in the flat so i went out for
a run but i've been in the prison cell
for the last month so i didn't have [ __ ]
for legs so i ran about three miles and
then was limping and just had to sort of
sadly limp back home
and start unpacking um so there is that
sort of first sense of almost
claustrophobia but i do find that starts
to wear off quicker and there's always
plenty to be getting back on with
normally coming back from a journey is
so busy i've got
uh i mean sadly lots of emails to answer
lots of you know friends to catch up
with you just kind of you rush back into
normal life and the first day might be a
bit claustrophobic and a bit
disorientating
and then that discombobulation dies away
for another couple of weeks suddenly you
might kind of go oh wow i'm just that
quickly back into a much more sedentary
lifestyle and that's when you start to
think right well what's next and then
you start focusing your attention on
whatever is next and uh and um that's a
good distraction
how do you commit to something which is
going to take four and a half years to
do
that was relatively straightforward
strangely straightforward um largely
because i was 22 at the time i was 21
when i decided to do it i think
and i had no ties really um i just had
my first job and so i was saving a
little bit of money but it wasn't
something that i wanted to do forever
and
um
i was a i think i mean i was young and i
was quite naive and i was able to just
make that rash decision and as i said
earlier it was that kind of you know
almost wanting to
essentially a homeric boast wanting to
do something big and bold and brash and
and sort of
you know
slay a dragon in my metaphorical sense
so that was actually quite
straightforward i made the decision i
was drunk at the time admittedly on uh
some mongolian vodka in a forest in
siberia um buy a little campfire
uh that's a longer story that i don't
think we've got time for now um but i
made that decision i drew some wiggly
lines on a little um in the back of a
lonely planet they had those tiny little
world maps and i kind of squiggled over
it i woke up in the morning looked at it
and thought right let's do that
and then just about a year later set off
and got going and the main thing about
that journey is i didn't really prepare
anything i didn't train i just saved a
bit of money i got a tent an old bicycle
and uh some pannier bags saddlebags to
carry everything and when i was ready i
just set off and it was kind of as
simple as that i suppose giving yourself
a
start date and telling people about what
you're gonna do is is a bit of a hack
because um if you're someone like me who
will be embarrassed to back down from
something they said they'll do you're
then in some sense committed um and that
seemed to work for me on on that
occasion and on several since then was
that a specialist bike of some kind did
it have any
important attributes that helped you to
survive for several thousand miles
no heavy steel frame um
no suspension
uh it would have cost i think about
three or four hundred pounds new i got a
second hand on ebay for about 100 pounds
um
i put it on
big seat
i wrote a
letter a handwritten letter
to a saddle maker called brooks
they make very beautiful
leather saddles they've been around for
150 years they're based in oxford or
oxfordshire i think
um and they're really expensive well i
mean they're not that expensive they're
about 150 pounds but that's more than i
had for even a bike
um and they over time they sort of
contour and mold to your ass and so they
fit
so i didn't have padded shorts i cycled
without padded shorts i just wore you
know boxer shorts and shorts or trousers
but i wrote them a letter saying i'm
going off to do this thing i'm going to
raise a bit of money for charity while i
do it i'm going to cycle 40 yard
thousand miles it'll take about four
years
um and at the end i said i honestly
think i can say that i'm speaking from
my ass when i say thank you very much
and they said they get hundreds of
requests every month um but due to that
one little kind of throwaway cheeky line
they said yeah here you go here's a
saddle um so that was perhaps the most
sort of specialist part of the bike was
just a saddle um i mean
40 000 miles
yeah
43 or 44 i think yeah you must be in the
top
1000 people on the planet in terms of
how far you've traveled on a bicycle
it's you and it's professional cyclists
and that's it
well
i mean there are many thousands of
professional cyclists so i mean okay i
might come in the top sort of you know
50 000 times
but that's still an awful lot and of
non-professional cyclists probably
easily within the top thousand people
that aren't doing it for the pursuit of
the sport even the amateurs and stuff
like that who chooses to go and do that
far
just
because adventure
yeah i mean the bicycle is a really good
means to an end when it comes to
adventure because you can travel for
nothing for free all you need is is food
to fuel you
um because you
you're always in the places in between
you get to see you get to really see a
place in in a really good depth
i suppose walking is is one level
further
um but you can still cover comfortably
60 to 100 miles a day and have time
besides to see people
meet people rather see things learn
things whatever
uh you can sleep for free in anywhere in
a tent you just pull over find a little
bit of woodland or in the desert or in
the mountains wherever you are you just
find some little space put up your tent
so you can travel for basically nothing
um for a really long distance at a pace
that is really conducive to
seeing the places that you are and sort
of scratching that bit deeper beneath
the surface and you're not just jetting
through places as you would on a train
or a plane or a car or a motorbike even
because you are traveling slowly enough
to force you to stop in lots of places
the villages uh between the towns that
other people might visit if they were
just on a shorter tour but not so slowly
as if you were perhaps walking that you
would never be able to get
from one place to another
quite so quickly and be able to see as
much
exactly i mean there was there's a
scottish guy called mark beaumont who
cycled 18 000 miles around the world in
78 and a half days i think a few years
back and he has the record for the but i
mean he was cycling
280 odd miles a day um with uh yeah it's
a porker it's a very different type of
experience to what i was aiming at and
the but the bike was just the means to
the end for me the end was to was to to
experience things to see to do to learn
how did you find yourself changed after
that
i was
browner
mostly from sort of dirt and grime
rather than actually a suntan i was
hairier
i had a sort of beard down to my nipples
pretty much by the end of it um
i was very very comfortable in my own
company potentially a little bit too
much so at first but i had spent
just
months and years by myself and had
learned to be really comfortable by
myself but that was a struggle it took
ages to kind of get that balance right
between
feeling uh
happily alone and feeling lonely
um so
that was probably the biggest difference
i guess also i've just seen a lot more
of the world and i i mean everyone is
very changed between 22 and 27 which is
the age i left and came back at so i was
probably different in as a slightly
evasive answer i guess
i always wonder about i've been thinking
about this a lot recently how much of
the wisdom that we like to attribute to
our own efforts and our personal
development and the bits of the world
that we've seen in the conversations
we've had and the introspection we've
done how much of that just comes along
for the ride as a byproduct of getting
older
a good chunk of it is is maybe just you
being having been around for another
year or two years or five years
absolutely and i think the you know for
most people thankfully the longer
they're around
the more confident they become within
themselves i mean this can lead to
problems you do get people who get a
little bit too confident perhaps and uh
you know with age they're more likely to
sort of you know
attain positions of power with which
they can
you know cause problems um but
predominantly i think we get more
confident as we get older and
confidence just kind of i think breeds a
fuller understanding of your life's
experience and the sum of your life's
experiences and that's going to happen
regardless of if you're
cycling around the world for four years
or you're
working in an office having day-to-day
experiences and interactions with lots
of different or the same people
we all grow and sort of broaden our
horizons throughout time and there's
lots of different ways of doing that and
that's why i've never been someone to
preach the idea that uh everyone should
travel and that travel is uniquely
transformative for me it has proved to
be very transformative but again as you
suggest potentially that's
just the passage of time
what places did you go to
that was surprisingly enjoyable
mentioned earlier on the dagestan was a
place that you went to that perhaps in
advance you wouldn't have thought of as
a
bastion of fun warm welcomeness
uh any any other places or places if
people are thinking that they fancy
going to do a trip that they should
probably consider that wouldn't be on
the typical list iran is probably the
most surprising place i've ever been to
now i assume that the majority of your
listeners will be british and american
and britain americans don't exactly get
an easy passage into iran you can't
this didn't used to be the case the
first two times i went you could travel
independently but now you need to be on
a tour with a guide and a sort of
pre-arranged itinerary so you can no
longer
quite experience it in the same way but
even so iran is and i've been i've
probably spent about six months there in
total it remains the friendliest place
i've ever been the single friendliest
place i've been to about half the
world's countries and iran stands out
head and shoulders above the rest for
just the
incredibly warm welcome and these are
people who know that i'm uh you know
just to sort of dispel the
slightly lazy stereotypes perhaps these
people who know that i'm not a
muslim potentially not even a practicing
religious person these are people who
know that i come from a country that um
doesn't particularly want good things
for for theirs or at least is
politically at loggerheads with them but
um iran is a good example i suppose this
loops back a little bit to what we were
talking about earlier with with russia
and russians iran is a great example
that
many people aren't and don't feel
represented by their governments and uh
their country is not just what we
see or hear in the news
a country is made up of well in iran's
case about 80 million people um and
there's a complete you know diversity
within that and the vast majority of
people i met the overwhelming majority
were incredibly warm friendly
interesting
um
open-minded on most topics but of course
people have been indoctrinated by a you
know state censorship and a lack of
access to the broader kind of market of
ideas
um but yeah that's the one place i would
say that surprised me most
interesting what about lessons that
you've taken from this i'm aware that
it's always difficult to kind of
synthesize something that you've been
doing for a decade and a half but if
there was a bunch of insights that you
think that you've gained or the ones
that you find most valuable that you
think other people should really take to
heart certainly seems like one of them
is that most of the world is quite warm
and welcoming and friendly and not
hostile i'm going to guess that that
might be something
yeah that's definitely
pretty much the default wherever i've
been in the world is for people normal
people authorities are often a slightly
different case but um normal people just
want to help out really um i
it probably helps that i have often
traveled in quite a vulnerable manner
without um uh
sort of
shows of visible
wealth for example you know i've
basically never had anything worth
robbing certainly not while traveling
traveling um
but
i mean i suppose the main thing which is
really hard to
to
phrase without sounding trite or cliche
but it's cliche for a reason is that you
i mean it makes you sound like some sort
of
um motivational speaker but
most people are a lot more capable than
they think they
if you set your sights a bit higher than
you expect then you will probably rise
up to meet them and if you don't you
will at least rise up to
you know higher than you'd expect and
failing well you know giving something a
go not completing it but
having done better than you ever
imagined you could is really really
valuable
now none of that is a secret and there
are many many people who charge
many many dollars or pounds out there to
uh to tell you that but it's quite a
straightforward truth uh and just making
that first step getting out your door
whether literally or metaphorically is
is the simple key to that just doing
something starting something and uh most
people will be surprised by what they
managed to uh to pull off
it's strange because
there's that the matthew principle to
those who have more
those who have everything more will be
given to those who have nothing more
will be taken and you start to see in
the world people
diverge
into
more of what it is that they're doing at
the moment and it's the inertia it's the
getting out of the door it's the
beginning of the first step it's
committing to doing the thing where
almost everybody gets stuck because once
you start to do the thing
not doing the thing takes more energy
than continuing to do the thing it's the
change i remember i was learning about
this guy i think he'd maybe swam
somewhere to the bahamas some insane
route that he'd done and he had to go
there and back
and he said that he wasn't emotional he
nearly died and there was all swells and
all sorts of chaos had ensued and the
only time that he ever really felt
emotion he said was when he got to land
and it was because of the deceleration
from what he'd felt to what he was
feeling now and i think that that's kind
of true just generally for when we're
trying to make changes changes right
it's not continuing to do the thing if
you're getting up on time and going to
the gym and you've got healthy
relationships and your food is okay and
you're not alcoholic
it that is what you tend to continue
doing yeah i mean one way of putting it
i suppose is that once you're
pressurized for a better term uh the
only thing that's sort of shocking or
jarring is depressurization or
decompression rather um you know once
you once you've got those wheels rolling
stopping is harder than just rolling
with it i agree charlie walker ladies
and gentlemen if people want to keep up
to date oh actually what are you doing
next tell us
what's up next for you well i've just
started work on a book about this
experience in russia but um you know
don't hold your breath watch this space
it'll be a while uh i've got a few ideas
bouncing around at the moment for what
journey will be next but uh i haven't
decided on anything yet so i'm not gonna
uh make any um loud boasts that i will
then feel forced to uh to stick to
regardless of the viability of them um
so in the meantime yeah people can keep
up with what i'm doing on instagram
cw explore it's the same on twitter at
cw explore my website cwxplore.com
there's a couple of books i've written
about my experiences which can be found
on
kindle and audible and
my website amazon wherever
um but yeah that's me for the time being
and i'm sure there'll be another journey
before long charlie i appreciate you
thanks mate my pleasure cheers what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]